that's a big
[ __ ] deal when like
when a band uh owns their own music
right so when you say like
your record label that means you own all
of your own publishing
music rights yeah well you know we
didn't we didn't wait around to try to
get
signed you know what i mean like a lot
of bands they'll they'll
yeah it's kind of like 22. it's catch-22
because
if you want to make it big you gotta be
signed to a label right if you want to
make money
you gotta own your own music so it's
like you're [ __ ] if you do
you're [ __ ] if you don't because if
you sign the label yeah you might blow
up
but then the labels got you for like a
five album deal before you get paid [ __ ]
and like and and if you put out your own
music on your own label yeah you own
your own
music you own the rights but nobody's
[ __ ] listening to it because nobody
knows about you because you don't have
the backing of the label
so very few artists have been able to do
that i mean what comes to mind is
is uh master p was like the initial
[ __ ] like he owned his own music
ah whether cash money [ __ ] birdman
like they aren't there on music
i can't think of a lot of others you
know but you know what though things are
changing now though
like like now there's almost [ __ ] man
things have changed so much recently
over the last
[ __ ] 20 years in the in the music
business that there's almost no
no need for a major label anymore i mean
you can
you know put something interesting out
together as poor video and slap it on
youtube
and blow the [ __ ] up all by yourself you
know i
put it on itunes and putting on all the
streaming out outlets
and you don't really need a a record
label for [ __ ]
i mean today you can do it yourself it's
so
accessible the industry is so it's it's
like it's almost
it's almost foolish to sign a major
label yeah i mean you know because you
got to give more than just
um you got to give what they call 360
deal now which
is you got to get your touring rights
all kinds of [ __ ] man
merchandise money everything you know
and it's like [ __ ] man
because um you know the record labels
are going to get paid one way or another
you know if they can't get paid selling
cds
they're going to get paid selling your
t-shirts or whatever you know
and you're saying the number of artists
that are blowing up on their own
doing it on their own is just it's like
feels like it feels like it's half the
industry you know and that's awesome
that's the [ __ ] man
you know like i look at the all these
artists that are like
huge pop stars today they came up on
their own
they were famous before they signed a
record deal right justin bieber's the
perfect example
exactly exactly there's i mean there's a
ton of them now
and it's it's the [ __ ] man it's like
it's almost
obsolete like record labels and even
studios even recording studios
they're almost no need for them anymore
because everything you need is
in a laptop like like we used to pay you
know 75 bucks an hour for studio
and for what i mean everything you need
now
it comes i mean my daughter can make a
beat on her phone
and it's yeah you know and she don't
have to even buy a special app for it
it just comes in the phone like that you
know what i mean it's like
if things are so different now that like
you can you can
get a microphone plug it into your
laptop get that
situation where they got the sound proof
around the microphone
and stick your headphones on and record
right there there's no need for a studio
there's literally like i heard uh one of
the biggest artists today dozier cat
our doji cat recorded all her hits in
her bedroom
with her brother you know these songs go
on platinum on the radio
and she did them in her bedroom you know
with her brother
that's [ __ ] awesome man that's what
music should be done you know
yeah i think billy eilish is a similar
story like one of her hits she made like
in a hotel room
just oh yeah supporting with your
brother too there's no re there's no
reason
to go out and spend all that money on a
big recording studio
i mean i record in a studio but it's my
studio
and it's just because i'm used to being
in a room that looks like that you know
what i mean
but [ __ ] man i mean like there's there's
i tell
artists that are starting out today all
you need is a good laptop
that's your record label that's your
management that's your studio
that's your everything you know what i
mean right on your laptop you know what
i mean you can do it all yourself man
it's not even hard to find out how to do
it either you know
it's it's really it's it's the lanes
there used to be
secret roads up the up the mountain as
we put it
but now they're like wide avenues like a
lot of the industry is is going up those
avenues you know
doing it themselves the the dyi is
everything now it's it's way bigger than
it was when we started out you know
for sure yeah dude